and it's yacht but again come on let's
do something else I'm not sure what is
playing here okay account Carla I'm not
an expert i'm going to try to play the
advanced this is probably the best line
against the car oh but i only know it
well I didn't know it is a big night
Bishop before check um I think I
recently saw this idea okay yeah it's
kind of rear ooting interesting it's
interesting what kind of things are
possible in the opening okay so let's
just play a normal move there and see
from here I don't know how do you play
him
ok i really i really don't don't know
this too well do I want to I mean I have
good control over c5 he's not so easily
playing that I wonder if I maybe I can
prepare like f 4g for not sure about
that but I have to do something
91 f 4g 4s my idea and I don't really
know if it's any good I have my doubts
he can play f6 maybe yeah okay so 93 I
guess maybe you can just play five here
right he's protecting that often enough
can my cam
okay jump that that should be ok for
black right I mean it's nothing terribly
bad for me but like has no problems here
I need to need to be careful queen here
maybe I really don't have more here than
just trading stuff I believe he has got
an extra sent upon him and good control
and it's very meeker just going for all
those traits but I don't really think I
have something great iam just have to be
modest and now I can take a seven but
here's night before I don't don't really
buy that I g-form had looked look too
dangerous ok so Bishop here right takes
it which can you take it for look age
five maybe he can
maybe you can take that after vision by
three huh interesting he's got active
pieces and he's very good at those kind
of pollution so have to be careful if
you give this guy in the tech he is very
very very dangerous yeah takes things
Ruby to gym but going into a self pin is
probably not the way to go that was
pretty quickly played was thinking I
might get some decent counter player D
ha but probably does that's not not
really the KSM is right there
my check for Queen III or something
check mmm yeah that's definitely true I
don't really have anything here takes
look on the seventh song it's never
enough job and that was a very bad
position right out of the opening how to
add to a play against the big center
so I can continue the fight but it's
really just just pawns I'm just pawns
down
see going from rookie to our no problem
that's good Jam that's good night c5 is
taking g4 with check
I am Jack can continue a couple of moves
check
only slide hope is some kind of check on
the light side learning this is pretty
good yeah Group chief for now okay right
now he said was the best position here
out of the opening really after after
have six I don't know maybe I should go
f4 or something but this also looks fine
for him why it's still better probably I
was really seeing too late that he gets
all this stuff in here in the center
this is very nice for black already I
mean not that I should be maybe I just
just played this year too in a too
simplistic way trading trading all that
stuff my f four years better right why
didn't a player for him fy5 now I was
too eager to trade stuff him and
simplify the position here it's nice I
wanted to go here originally but he can
take hmm check hmm ok challenge here
yeah now that wasn't really good already
a bad game and this is also just bad I
can I didn't want to go here I can do
that why not I'm going moving the bishop
next with the rook on f6 he cannot
triple on the e-file this is just equal
disposition okay yet yeah I'm just lost
jack just lost and he did a good job
down no it was a bad game simply I
shouldn't experiment against this guy is
not a good idea okay well thanks for
watching